finds himself in a tie for first at the
end of the sing field go bedazzle does
well he showed why he is indeed a
champion grinding down this position
past 100 moves and finally winning to
tie for first in the Sinquefield cup
Magnus you must have thought at one
point no way in the world this position
is so solid what do I have to do to win
and then he started making some moves
that gave you some chances well I mean
technically it wasn't past 200 most I
think it was just short but you know I I
thought I had a promising position early
on I mean the the line he goes for is
it's very solid but it's also a little
bit sad for for black and then I think
this whole thing with Bishop h6 wasn't
as good as I thought rukia it was really
nice defensive move and and yeah I mean
later on after the time control I just
felt like I just have to keep the game
going
I mean I didn't have any particular
hopes but you know there was only a wind
that mattered so I just had to have to
keep pushing and obviously when I
managed to trade Queens I was a little
bit more optimistic since I've done at
least I had had a goal and he almost has
too much time because he has so many
defensive plans to choose from and I
suspect all of them actually work but
you know you start to see some dangers
and and you know eventually start to
panic
and I think that's that's what happened
to him you feel the move a 5 a 5 g 5
plan was just one warranted yeah I know
I think already when after he went h5 g5
h 5e he he found this very very
unpleasant like I mean certainly i-5
wasn't necessary but I think it was at
that point the practical decision for
him thinking that he wasn't going to
wait for me to gradually sneak up on his
iPhone but the king he just wanted to
give it away
but I suppose he had underestimated my
plan with the King to be a it and then
it all seems to work out very well for
whites someone said there was a similar
structure with MVL scuse me that was
played did you see that game no I mean
Peter just told me now that he had a
game with with game skill I was exactly
the same that's kind of kind of funny
but yeah I mean the idea is in general
well known to - hides to hide behind
these pawns with with the king and it's
it's funny that at the end material is
equal and it doesn't look all that bad
friend he's actually when he resigns his
opponent doesn't matter you tied excuse
me
you're tied for first in the tournament
the feeling of winning the last game no
it's it's great I mean it just makes the
whole difference from a mediocre
tournament to a good one so now I've you
know I've gained rating and I've shared
first place so that's that's a that's
quite different from whatever fourth or
fifth so what I would be able to drunk
you've never ever actually finished
worse than second in the Sinquefield Cup
but must be filled most feel very
satisfying yeah I mean it was a bit
similar to last year that I was training
by half a point with with +1 and then I
was the one last round of the last round
but my same one as well so I don't know
it's just it's extremely tough to grind
out wins against this guy so I'm pretty
happy with with +2 congratulations
excellent result and hope to see you
again next year thank you